[Music]
right here right now it just doesn't
feel right
Ben you didn't find love in winter games
you chose to leave do you still feel
good about that decision I feel really
good about that decision it was the
right time I found myself looking around
this is what happened I was sitting on
the couch and all the couples were
making out around me at different places
around the living room and I was like
yeah I don't think it's my time here
anymore
okay Yuki and I had too many snowball
fights and it's time for me to go but
you know we saw this really emotional
moment from you talking to Chris and I
have to say I it was hard to watch only
because I know you're such a great guy
and I was like I'm really seeing kind of
how hurt he was how deep was that hurt
that you went through and where are you
at with it now
these shows kind of put you in this
environment where you really have to dig
deep and you have to talk about
relationships and love and you start to
realize him things that you never knew
you felt as soon as we broke up as soon
as it was announced I was getting
questions did you really love her or
other things like hey I wish you would
have chosen somebody else and so I was
finding myself either protecting Lauren
defending our relationship or maybe
having to respond to the fact that yeah
they love Lauren I'd say yeah I did too
I do too I don't you know and it broke
me because something that it was really
personal and really real and really hard
was something I also had to relive every
day there's not a day that goes by that
Lauren isn't brought into my life and as
you're trying to heal from a breakup it
crushes you
[Music]